by the way the entire we don't do
confirmation hearings during the last
year of a presidency thing Mitch
McConnell has basically now admitted
that that rule is not really a rule
you'll remember that a month after
Supreme Court Justice Antonin Scalia
passed away in February of 2016
President Obama nominated federal judge
Merrick garland to take his place on the
court Mitch McConnell the Senate leader
refused to schedule hearings for the
nomination saying listen it's the last
year of Obama's presidency we shouldn't
confirm anybody during the last year of
during an election year let's wait for
the next president to get their chance
to decide it was almost completely
unprecedented for the Senate to block a
nominee on these grounds and Garland's
nomination just SAT there before the
Senate for more than twice as long as
any other Supreme Court nomination in
history and it really was unprecedented
in the sense that current Supreme Court
Justice Anthony Kennedy was nominated by
Ronald Reagan and confirmed during an
election year this week Chuck Todd ask
Mitch McConnell if he'd be willing to
advocate for a Senate resolution that
would codify that you do not confirm
Supreme Court nominees in an election
year here's what Mitch McConnell had to
say about this what was wrong with
allowing Merrick garland to have an
up-or-down vote I all ready to already
told you you don't fill Supreme Court
vacancies in the middle of a
presidential election should that be the
policy going forward are you prepared to
pass a resolution it says in election
years any Supreme Court vacancy and have
it to be the sense of a Senate
resolution that say no Supreme Court
nominations will be considered in any
even-numbered year is that what we're
headed there chuck it all due respect
that's an absurd question what is absurd
about it if Mitch McConnell is so
committed to this principle we don't do
confirmation hearings for the supreme
court during election years why is he
laughing at the idea of making it a rule
McConnell told Todd that it would be an
absurd that it is an absurd question if
this is such an important practice apply
it to future
presidency or is Mitch McConnell only
interested in using this idea when it
suits Republican take a listen to this
look yeah we litigated that last year
the American people decided they wanted
Donald Trump to make the nomination not
redundant and what's before us now Chuck
is not what happened last year but the
qualifications of Neil corsets
unanimously well qualified by the
American Bar Association the American
people decided in 2008 and in 2012 that
for the four-year presidential term
following it would be Barack Obama who
decides who fills Supreme Court
vacancies but let's forget about last
year and change to the subject of Neil
Gorsuch and how great he is he's not
great he's not great and that is a
completely separate issue which of
course Mitch McConnell would like to
distract from this is a total and utter
distraction and it is Mitch McConnell's
long-standing practice to obstruct
anything that he can and then to take
advantage of being able to avoid
obstruction when it's his Republicans
chance or opportunity to make a decision
about politics and their obstruction of
Merrick garland set a horrible precedent
because now Democrats have no choice to
fight back what else are they going to
do roll over yeah and this means that
going forward Supreme Court justices
will only get appointed or confirmed
when the president and the Senate are in
the same party and it's probably going
to have to be a simple majority from now
on once this happened basically all
decorum and precedent was thrown out the
window and two only now blame Democrats
for trying to obstruct is really missing
the forest for the trees this is being
discussed on our reddit discussion forum
I encourage you to join us there at
david pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program is made possible in part by
gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream
games through your Amazon fire stick or
Roku box and then use your mobile phone
as the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30 day free
trial at gamefly offer.com / TDPS the
games are shipped directly to you with
return envelopes included no contracts
and you can also stream the games I
think I mentioned that you can also rent
games through the mobile app get a free
30-day trial for david pakman show
viewers and listeners and support our
show at gamefly offer.com /td PS